what's an idea right now that you'd want
to do that you don't have the money for
I don't know why I'm drawing dead I
can't think of any I mean recently again
because of peaceful and beastware a lot
of those ideas like like an example it's
a video we just filmed I uh I went to
the cheapest hotel on the planet and I
worked my way up to the most expensive
one spent a night there so one dollar
Hotel all the way up to a million
dollars tonight Hotel like that video
was wildly expensive but you know now
that we have more Revenue coming in I
could afford it so most of the bigger
ones we're now getting to the point
where we can you spent a million bucks
just for one night in a hotel Yeah so
basically it's like people do it for
like weddings or sweet 16s like these
really rich people massive like massive
massive Castle they do like a drone show
they bring in like a celebrity chef and
give you like a 40 course meal it's just
a whole itinerary of just crazy [ __ ] and
yeah it's a million dollars a night and
was it cool yeah it was [ __ ] cool so
you rented medieval times for a night
basically oh oh [ __ ] oh yo you're
looking Dapper Mr Beast how's it going
man hi my name is Hugh Montgomery I'm
with the IRS [ __ ] [ __ ] do you have a
couple of minutes sir no I don't okay I
need my lawyer someone get him in here
with these questions you won't require
representation it's just a little
interview if you don't mind okay okay
your Burgers first of all okay very good
thank you yeah what do you think of my
FIT I bought it
because I'm rich you're from the IRS you
don't have to hold back you can say
whatever you want don't smell it uh no I
don't want to smell it but if we get
right to it though Mr Beast how much
money did you make in 2021 sir uh I give
it all away I'm poor you're poor yes sir
what were your gross earnings uh
negative
hey I paid you a [ __ ] load of taxes last
year okay I did even though I didn't
make money they still make me pay well
sir something that's right you didn't
pay me specifically gotcha you're paying
the country all right which ordered you
the opportunity
yes how much I got if I give you like
hypothetically 100 Grand can you knock
like 150 off my tax bill that's not for
me to decide sir I'm only here to
collect information but I'm saying if I
do and you do that we can get a good
thing going possibly could okay okay
[Laughter]
is it a bit and I'm like literally I get
arrested tomorrow you're asking the IRS
guy to smell your Gucci tracks bro you
know I mean
the funniest thing they could have done
is if this was a real IRS agent and then
I go to jail he doesn't really look like
he's [ __ ] yeah I mean he is staring
at me I'm getting a little intimidated
so again I'm pressed for time okay so
take a few minutes okay continue yes how
much did you pay in taxes in 2021 sir
enough a lot more than I should a number
sir I don't know I I have a accounting
team that does it well let me ask you
something like this how much money do
you currently have in your checking
account
uh none I'm poor
now we can do this here in front of
millions of people yeah or we can do
this in private I don't really want to
fight I'm sorry no okay there's no
fighting oh okay it's just the IRS
okay how much money are you giving away
today sir uh today Yes actually I
already gave away 110 000 today that's
good to who uh some guy Croatia
[Laughter]
I'm being dead serious I did I
understand and realized that you had
this remind me after this wealth I do
I'm rich however to whom much is given
much is expected 100 excellent and I'm
glad we understand each other on that
I heard you say you buy your prizes back
uh-huh yes sir are you paying any taxes
on those prices uh well they are so like
if I give them an island and we sell it
get a million dollars I'll give them
600k and we'll pay the 400k taxes for
them oh my God you pay 400k taxes yeah
whatever it is we let the tax man tell
us
he did actually write that down
well Mr Beast I can see that this is not
a proper use of time or the government's
time agreed so with that but you did
just get 87 000 agents true yeah that's
got nothing to do you're good for they
can afford to let you see here all day
and then I could yes but unfortunately I
have other rich people to attend to as
well they don't have tits like this
that they don't sir agreed Mr Beast
thank you for your time no problem I'd
fist pump you but you declined my last
one
and the IRS does not fist pump
[Laughter]
g'day sir good day good day sir thank
you thank you thank you for stopping in
thank you for stopping in bro I tricked
that noob
that was great I think I'm poor that was
awesome that was a great bit you killed
it no we're clapping because you're done
like you're that was literally an IRS
agent and you're going to jail oh [ __ ] I
don't know who that was bro he thought I
was poor but look at this fit man bro
why do you believe me
clearly I got money
bro that was a good bit you guys killed
it you know on my podcast tour none of
them have done that bro oh we're bumping
them up